here's what would happen if you were  bitten by one million mosquitoes  when the first mosquito lands and takes  a bite  you probably won't feel a thing  what you would notice though is the  itchy red swelling around the bite  now if you were bitten by 220 000  mosquitoes you'd lose approximately 20  percent of your blood  you'd have major organ failure as your  heart would lose the pressure needed to  circulate your blood you'd become pale  confused and weak and you'd most likely  slip into a coma  but your nightmare wouldn't end there  if one million mosquitoes bit you they  would drain all five and a half liters  of blood from your body  each square centimeter of your skin  would get bitten 62 times  once the mosquitoes were done you'd just  be a raw bloody dead mess  so watch out for these insects because